what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with another installment of our
beyond omega level series where we
discuss the most powerful characters in
comics and today we're diving into the
dc universe specifically the green
lantern lore and discussing the
guardians of the universe so the
guardians of the universe were created
by john broom and gil kane and first
appeared in green lantern number one in
1960. now the guardians are one of the
oldest races in the entire universe and
originally lived on a planet called
maltis and looked essentially like blue
humans now they valued science learning
and discovery above everything else and
one fateful day one resident of maltest
named krona was experimenting with time
manipulation to try and observe the
universe's origin which resulted in the
universe being split up into several
different universes that would make up
the dc multiverse and so resulted in the
creation of court a universe made of
antimatter which is where the
anti-monitor was said to be from before
dc retconned that now to try and atone
for creating a chaotic disorganized
universe the residents of malta leave
their home planet and take up residence
on owa a planet at the center of the
universe itself and it's on owa that
some of the maltrusions become the
guardians of the universe devoted to
preserving law and order in the universe
itself and they also get a lot shorter
and their heads get a lot bigger for
some reason but regardless the
guardian's first attempt at keeping
peace in the galaxy came in the form of
the man hunters which were basically an
android police force that the guardians
created and that worked pretty well for
a few million years until something went
wrong with the programming of the
manhunters and they rebelled against the
guardians and began killing people
instead of protecting them now after the
guardians defeat the rogue man hunters
they decommission the rest of them and
get to work on creating a replacement
police force now the reality here is the
reason why the manhunter's programming
went awry is because cronus screwed with
him but not wanting a repeat of the man
hunters the guardians decided that they
actually needed to use living beings
this time so to that end they create the
green lantern corps now members of the
green lantern corps are chosen based on
their willpower by power rings that get
their power from perhaps the greatest
scientific achievement of the maltusions
the central power battery located on owa
which basically powers the rings through
smaller batteries or lanterns that each
member of the green lantern corps
carries with them and the fact that the
guardians created the green lantern
corps is really all the evidence we need
that they are beyond omega level because
the green lanterns themselves are
powerful enough to be considered omega
level and at this point in a video about
pretty much any dc character i usually
have to explain how all of this was
changed by the various reboots that dc's
done over the years but thankfully the
green lantern mythos has largely
remained unchanged by both christ's
undefined earth and the new 52 the only
real big difference here is that instead
of the guardians of the universe just
being able to tap into the emotional
spectrum arbitrarily one day instead it
was the first lantern vault thumb a guy
from an alternate reality that taught
them how to do that now they attempted
to create a lantern by using volthume
and then everything went belly up but
that's how they learned to tie or at
least to access the emotional spectrum
was through vulthum the first lantern
and that actually came out of the green
lantern new 52 run but in terms of
powers the guardians have so many
abilities that listing them all is quite
difficult but i'll try to cover most of
them here so first of all they're
virtually immortal insofar as they would
likely live forever but they can die in
fact almost all of the guardians of the
universe did die during the events of
emerald twilight which took place in
green lantern issues 48-50 in 1994 where
hal jordan famously becomes the villain
known as parallax now this event sees
how jordan rebuild coast city after it
had been destroyed which is a violation
of the lantern corps rules and brings
him into conflict with the guardians now
this makes hal really pissed off and he
goes to owa to steal the central power
battery's energy to rebuild coast city
causing the guardians to release former
green lantern sinestro from his
imprisonment in the battery to try and
stop how now sinestro is eventually
killed by hal who also kills his former
teammate kilowatt and so in a last-ditch
effort to stop howe the guardians
transfer all their energy to one of
their members ganthet who becomes the
sole survivor of the guardians while the
rest of them die as well now shortly
thereafter while hal is still parallax
he battles green lantern kyle raynor and
the battle eventually destroys owa
itself but both owa and the guardians
are restored by kyle rayner recharging
the central power battery now in
addition to immortality the guardians of
the universe also possess near
omniscience and cosmic awareness as well
as vast telepathic and telekinetic
abilities the guardians are also able to
create and control hard light constructs
just like the green lanterns but to an
even more advanced degree with the
guardians having created constructs
strong enough to restrain sinestro as
well as the green lantern jon stewart
furthermore they are durable to the
point of being practically invulnerable
and can phase teleport and create
illusions and honestly the way they've
been depicted it seems like they're
basically omnipotent with the ability to
manipulate time matter and energy to the
point of being able to alter reality
itself now just to run over a few of the
feats the guardians of the universe have
done ganfit was able to destroy kilowog
a ridiculously powerful green lantern
with relative ease and was able to
incapacitate multiple green lanterns
simultaneously ganthet was also able to
damage some incredibly powerful enemies
including superboy prime although doing
so resulted in gandit's destruction he
was also able to harm the anti-monitor
and according to kyle raynor could
destroy a planet with merely a single
thought the guardians also displayed
vast abilities to manipulate genetics as
they actually gave the martian race
their weakness to fire to prevent a
segment of the martians the burning
martians themselves who were constantly
on fire from achieving space travel and
conquering other planets the guardians
were also able to imprison parallax the
embodiment of fear in the dc universe
within the central power battery and
were able to open a portal leading to
the afterlife they've shown the ability
to realign planets and stars and reverse
quantum singularities which are
basically points of entropy or chaos
which threaten the existence of the
universe itself the guardians were also
responsible for the creation of an
entire species when their experiments on
maltose and reptiles resulted in the
evolution of the scion race which would
themselves become a highly advanced
society so despite looking like little
blue oompa loompas the guardians of the
universe are quite powerful although
they sometimes suffer from being used in
storylines to be defeated by some really
powerful villain to show how powerful
that villain is still the fact that they
can destroy planets with a thought
definitely lets us know that they are
beyond omega level not to mention the
fact that they are able to control all
of the forces of the universe time
energy matter and reality itself so if
you guys enjoyed this video let me know
down in the comment section and as
always let me know who it is that you
want to see thank you all for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace